[Music]
marin jimmy mickey and of course kerry
the biggest names in country music
gather for the big night lots of
newcomers and of course the veterans
with leanne rimes celebrating over two
decades in country music and a new album
i don't think there's any emotion we
didn't touch on on this album it will
rip your heart out
it will piss you off it will do all the
things and i love that
as for host kelsey ballerini she is
forced to work from home it's been a
crazy year in country hey is is this
thing on or
are you guys really trying to get rid of
me
and perform from her own backyard
virtually due to covid but in typical
kelsey form she kills it
i couldn't wait till later talking in
the elevator kissing
co-host anthony mackie is joined by kane
brown for support kelsey's been very
supportive she's helped out a lot we got
kane brown to step in and he's a veteran
jason aldean and carrie underwood if i
didn't love you as for the big winners
of the night snapping up not one but two
trophies carrie underwood and jason
aldean steal the show this one's all
about the fans man so thank you fans
thank you cmt we've been in this in this
game for a while now and
for the fans to just still support us
like they do it's it's really wonderful
and it means a lot to us i told carrie
tonight i was like when we walked off
after we won the first award i told her
i was like man i didn't realize you know
all i had to do was record a song with
you and i could win some awards q a
costume change for carrie to sing her
latest single ghost story
well jason joins a legend on stage for a
very canadian collaboration with none
other than brian adams
[Music]